військові Передають що слухають нас
дивляться дуже слідкують за тим як ми
тут Приймаємо рішення ще запрошують
Провести засідання парламенту десь
поближче до часового яру десь поближче
до купінська десь поближче до работіна
здається військовим і чесно скажучи мені
теж здається що тоді багато речей
проясниться і ми будемо краще приймати
рішення розуміючи справжні пріоритети ні
бара ні серіали Ні бруківка справжні
пріоритети які є сьогодні в державі і
пропозиція ще одна закликаю Провести
засідання парламенту і комітетів Я вже
пропонував в тому числі нашого
бюджетного в тих самих місцях чому би це
не зробити пан Микола Тіщенко якщо
присутній хочеться почути його думку Чи
готовий він їхати там провести там може
є кол-центр